[Music]
dear kitten
since i have hissed you the customary
437 times
it is now my duty as the head of the
household to
begrudgingly welcome you perhaps you are
here to replace me
but i must do my duty and educate you on
your new surroundings
as maximilian once did for me rest in
peace
dear kitten this room here is basically
a crapshoot
either you get the petting of your life
and i mean two hands like you don't even
know what's going on
or they just lie there and don't do
anything for hours it's weird
oh and i should also point out on
special occasions they will leave the
underwear drawer open to signal their
appreciation
of me just to be clear it's my spot
it's perfect in there it's like sleeping
surrounded by underwear
well i mean that's exactly what it is
dear kitten
i remember when i could fit in a shoe
there's nothing like it
being engulfed in 360 degrees of foot
smell
enjoy it while you can dear kitten
because you are so small you cannot jump
which is sad sad for you but eventually
you will
and you will find the places that i
refer to as
up this will come in handy especially
around the human larva
which i know smells like milk but can be
a bit
grabby dear kitten you should be aware
that there are two kinds of food
the first is sort of a dehydrated brown
niblet
i think they give us these because
they're training us to be
astronauts just a guess the second kind
is wet food
it is so special they keep it in little
armored metal casings
that no claw can penetrate with no claws
to speak of
the humans can somehow open them it's
like some dark magic dear kitten
i should warn you of the monster known
as vacuum it can
eat and yell at the same time and i've
seen it eat everything
seriously like a paper clip and two cat
toys didn't even flinch to hide from
vacuum
you may use the curtains of invisibility
oh yeah you're good good hiding oh boy
dear kitten one final note once in a
while you might see a little
red dot i'm going to tell you this right
now
it is real and it can be caught i did it
once
i held it for a full minute but when i
lifted my paws
it was gone so kitten
welcome to the household
you'll do just fine
oh